why is it hard for writers to talk about
theme it's hard for everybody to talk
about theme nobody understands theme I
mean that's a horrible thing to say that
nobody understands theme like oh as if I
understand it's just theme is so complex
and so it's like ethereal it's like it's
the proverbial trying to nail Jello to a
wall trying to understand theme it's
like you know the
[Music]
you can get all intellectual about it
and I and I already regret saying like
nobody understands things because I'm
sure there are people out there who
teach in you know in college level
courses you know and and deal heavily
with theme and they can talk very
intelligently about theme
um I don't care because I don't know
that that this super super intellectual
understanding of theme helps you write
one damn word again I want people to
have careers I want people to put money
on their table your money in their
pockets and food on their table and you
know you get all
highfalutin and you know ethereal
talking about themes and how they
interrelate with the and it's like okay
well you talk about that for a while but
why don't you write something so I I so
for me I I just try to figure out okay
I'm not that smart I just want to figure
out what's the simplest
understanding of theme possible that
will help me write
you know a a story and and that's kind
of where I stumbled across the this idea
of
you know you know it's defining theme
very simply as you know Heroes
ask questions and villains make
arguments
and and that was kind of it I know I
know it seems a little bit strange and
simplistic to do it but but that's kind
of the the way to approach it you know
where it's like there's sort of it and I
guess is a classic basis for it where
it's like you know thesis antithesis and
synthesis right so you know so you know
you go to
um let's see what's a good one
trying to think you know this idea of
trying to think like a really good
example
for theme where you know where
um okay let's we'll use Star Wars again
okay so this theme you know from a
big view is science versus technology
what's more powerful science versus
technology right it's just a theme you
can have all sorts of themes you know is
love love for family better stronger
than love for the Universe I don't know
you know so you can come up with
anything you want whatever helps you
tell the story go with it right don't
don't think there's got to be one
absolute so for me I want the theme the
the accessible thing that I could hang
my hat on to tell a story in Star Wars
for theme is you know it's science
versus technology right and then you go
okay Heroes you know make ask questions
what's stronger you know science versus
technology you know Faith the force
versus you know versus you know Jedis
versus the Empire right you know you
know with Empire representing technology
right the Death Star is a big ball of
Technology you know as compared to the
you know the Jedis which is you know
little you know a vanishingly small
group of people who are involved in
faith right so so Luke asks not verbally
but this is Luke's thematic journey is
what's more powerful he goes I don't
know what's more powerful science versus
or technology I don't know so he's going
to spend the whole story pondering that
um the if you ask the you know the
you know Emperor or Darth Vader or
general you know you know governor of
Tarkin you know on a death star like
Technologies you know Vader has an
appreciation for for Faith but he
himself is a product of Technology Luke
is asking the question what's more
powerful Faith or technology and he
grapples with that throughout the entire
story right everything is about you know
is about that
um the all the bad guys have no such
questions they make the argument
technology is strong like Darth Vader is
a result of Technology he had faith and
it didn't
save him back when he had his fight with
Obi-Wan
so Faith let him down he's now surviving
based on technology the Death Star is a
giant ball of flashy blinky technology
right it's like you know the faith is
gone from the universe right you my
friend are all that's left of you know
your faith or whatever you know whatever
is said to him
um so the bad guys have no such
questions they are convinced they make
the argument that that technology is
stronger than faith Luke is uncertain
and what does he learn finally at the
end is that faith and Technology can
work together right and that's where you
get the ultimate strength right because
he uses
he uses when he destroys the Death Star
he shuts off the targeting computer
which is him rejecting technology use
the force Luke right he's embracing
Faith but it's like it's not like he
does one of you know the Obi-Wan two
finger air move and the death star
explodes he still uses technology to
destroy the Death Star he might use the
Torpedoes so he's using technology in in
concert with faith and that's the
strongest of all so it's a really
interesting lesson right that you don't
have to you don't have to reject you
don't have to be Amish right where
you're rejecting technology right and
you don't have to be you know sort of a
scientific atheist where you're
completely rejecting Faith you can be
somebody who's embracing everything that
the world has to offer in terms of both
spirituality and technology and that's
where you get sort of a complete person
so so for me that's how you tell a story
thematically that's that's what you need
so anything more complicated than that
if if you feel like
you know it's like it you know they they
talk about like what was the Brilliance
of of Trader Joe's over Ralphs right so
you go to Ralph's and you want to buy
ketchup right so you go to you look at
the ketchup aisle and you've got 45
types of ketchup right and you just
don't know which one to buy so you
probably go back to the Neil Hines or
whatever it is you're used to buying
Trader Joe's has like one you got two
types of ketchup right so they realize
that that that
it seems like giving people a lot of
choices
is the right thing to do it feels kind
of magnanimous in some weird way but it
leads to
the proverbial you know analysis
paralysis so the same thing with
thinking about seeing that people you
know have all these great and I'm not
saying they're invalid they're just not
helpful theories about about theme and
how theme Works in in a story so to me
it's like they all might be right and it
all might be fine and everybody who's
taking a college level course and theme
I wish you the best of luck and I'd love
to talk to you about it over you know
over Tito's one day however
if it doesn't
Empower you to write your story fast
then it's useless
absolutely useless again I'm strict I'm
like if it if it's if it delays you
getting a check
by two weeks that's two weeks wasted so
yeah so I I like to go with like what's
the minimum amount of theme you need to
tell a story and the minimum amount I
found over and over again is you know
Heroes ask questions and villains make
arguments